stained-glass windows at beauty and
light to places of worship over time
exposure to the elements and pollution
can cause the glass metal framework and
glazing to deteriorate restoration
ensures the survival of these sacred
works of art for future generations it
starts with a thorough evaluation an
Assessor photographs the window she
examines every part as well as measures
the panes and connecting LED strips
known as Kames
these caves are in bad shape so they'll
need to completely disassemble the panel
and rebuild it first they make a rubbing
a member of the team places a large
sheet of paper over the back of the
window
he rubs a wax crayon over the raised LED
strips to transfer the pattern of the
panes after testing the condition of the
paint on the panes he submerges the
glass in a non acidic cleaning solution
and leaves it overnight this softens the
glazing cement between the LED strips so
the window can be easily disassembled he
extracts the glass and cleans off the
glazing using the straight-edged razor
most of the panes are in good condition
and can be preserved but one is
fractured and held together with special
conservation tape they'll need to
replace it
a craftsperson traces the outline of the
cracked piece onto a new piece of glass
then cuts the glass along the tracing
lines
she copies the designs onto the new pane
and mixes a matte paint that matches the
one on the broken pane
she then shades the designs on the new
pane with the matte paint she removes
some of the paint following the designs
on the pane
this creates highlights she fires the
glass in a hot kiln and then lowers the
temperature to anneal it she joins all
the stained glass panes using new LED
canes
she taps the panes gently with a rubber
mallet to fit them snugly into the
grooves of the caves
using an electric soldering iron she
melts Tynan lead solder where the
channeled LED strips intersect another
team member applies glazing cement
across the front and back of the stained
glass panel he sprinkles calcium
carbonate onto the wet cement it's known
as whiting the whiting soaks up excess
oil in the glaze as he brushes it off it
cleans and polishes the panel finally he
vacuums up the glazing residue it's
taken about a week to restore the
stained glass window it should last
another century or more providing plenty
of opportunities for spiritual
reflection